nearly 50 years after it happened a
group of researchers has a new theory
about what caused Bruce Lee's shocking
death at age 32 that seems to tie in
with the cause officials cited does it
hold up here's what we know the sudden
death of action star Bruce Lee on July
20 1973 in Hong Kong has stoked dozens
of questions and theories in the decades
that have ensued speculation from fans
colleagues and biographers has resulted
in a cloudy public perception of what
really killed the seemingly healthy
Legend snopes.com cites a 2018 example
of such speculation from a biography by
author Matthew Pauley that suggests the
actor's lack of sweat glands may have
contributed to his death by heat stroke
that's just one of many rumors about
Lee's death which have been bandied
about in the nearly five decades since
he lost his life which have included
everything from Foul Play to steroid
abuse according to Real's Channel's
podcast for their program autopsy the
last hours of Bruce Lee variety reports
that the official cause of Lee's death
was listed by Hong Kong officials in
Hong Kong as Serena liberal edema
swelling of the brain but a new group of
researchers has cast even more doubt on
the official report this group of
Medical Specialists has posited a fresh
theory about what exactly caused Lee's
sudden demise he was alive and well and
he was being Bruce Lee and he was on the
verge of achieving everything he'd ever
dreamed of and the next he just was gone
a report published by a group of Spanish
kidney researchers in the December 2022
issue of the clinical kidney Journal
suggests that Bruce Lee may have died
from hyponatremia meaning his body
lacked critical levels of salt due to
his heavy water intake the end result
was that his kidneys were unable to
process the massive amount of fluids he
consumed on a daily basis with his
organs unable to excrete all the water
in his body hyponatremia set in followed
by the cerebral edema the paper includes
a laundry list of contributing factors
related to this conclusion including
prescription drug usage The Thirst
caused by marijuana consumption and
previous organ injuries the paper
concludes we hypothesized that Bruce Lee
died from a specific form of of kidney
dysfunction the inability to excrete
enough water to maintain water
homeostasis this may lead to
hyponatremia cerebral edema and death
within hours if excess water intake is
not matched by water excretion in urine
the researchers add that hyponatremia is
found in around 40 percent of
hospitalized people and might contribute
to the deaths of even The Young and the
healthy this also supports the
researchers belief that more people
should be aware of the dangers of
excessive fluid intake naturally this
conclusion is only a medical hypothesis
and may or may not be contradicted with
time and further study according to Fox
News Lee's family has not responded to
requests for comment on these new
findings Paulie's 2018 biography Bruce
Lee a life also hypothesized that over
consumption of water may have been a
contributing factor in Lee's abrupt
death Polly told Fox news that a
previous medical problem may also be a
factor in the actor's passing the key to
understanding Bruce Lee's death is that
he collapsed 10 weeks before and almost
died of the very same thing on May 10
1973 he walked into a small dubbing room
on one of the hottest days of the month
they turned off the air conditioner to
avoid ruining the soundtrack Lee
overheated and collapsed outside of the
recording room he recovered but once he
returned to the booth he began to
experience convulsions after collapsing
once again Lee was taken to the hospital
and while doctors suspected brain
swelling lease ailment was written off
as being a minor case of heat stroke but
Polly believes that Lee's untreated heat
stroke was so severe It ultimately led
to his death abetted Pali claims by the
removal of the sweat glands in his
underarms and the day he died was the
hottest day of the month in Hong Kong
and so I think it was heat stroke that
killed him Lee's Widow Linda Lee
Caldwell maintained in a 1998 article
published in the Los Angeles Times that
she believes a painkiller that included
an ingredient Bruce Lee was sensitive to
was behind his passing she wrote Bruce
died from cerebral edema caused by
hypersensitivity to an ingredient in a
prescription medication called equigizic
the determination was made after an
exhaustive nine-day coroners in quest
during which the testimony of forensic
Pathologists from all over the world who
had studied every tissue in Bruce's Body
Was Heard
[Music]